à l'étranger barack obama est en passe
de gagner son pari
le sénat américain devrait donner ce
midi son feu vert à la réforme de
l'assurance maladie
une véritable révolution après des mois
de négociations acharnées
c'est une étape importante mais tout
n'est pas encore gagné
nora boubetra ils ont tout fait pour
éviter un vote en plein réveillon de
noël
alors ils l'ont avancé cet après-midi le
sénat américain devrait adopter sa
version de la loi sur la réforme de
santé
un succès politique de premier plan pour
barack obama qui a retardé son départ en
vacances de quelques heures pour
attendre le vote
je ne suis jamais complètement satisfait
mais là je suis très content j'ai dit
que je voulais que tous les gens
dépourvus d'assurance santé puissent en
avoir une
elle va couvrir 30 millions d'habitants
qui en étaient privés jusqu'à maintenant
le texte vise à fournir une couverture à
tous ces millions d'américains qui en
sont dépourvus et à faire baisser les
coûts tout en améliorant la qualité des
soins
mais avec ce projet de loi largement
amendé sous la pression de l'ailé droite
du parti démocrate
6 % des américains de moins de 65 ans
resteront en dehors du système
autre bémol le texte ne prévoit pas la
création d'une caisse d'assurance
maladie gérée par l'état
malgré tout cette réforme reste une
victoire pour barack obama
ça n'est pas la réforme 100% qu'ils
souhaitaient obama mais c'est une
réforme très importante avec comme axes
principaux y aura environ 30 millions
d'américains supplémentaires qui seront
assurés y aura de vrais moyens pour
contrôler les coûts de la santé et les
pratiques des compagnies d'assurance
donc ça n'est pas totalement la réforme
qu'obama souhaitait c'est une réforme de
compromis mais elle reste historique
très importante
les républicains ont tout tenté pour
bloquer la réforme mais ils n'ont pas
dit leur dernier mot avant d'être
promulgué le projet doit être entériné
par les deux chambres du congrès qui
vont devoir se mettre d'accord sur un
texte commun